con estos haitianos consiguen rescatar
con vida a una joven de los escombros
está evidentemente debilitada
[Música]
unos segundos después atrapados en el
mismo lugar
estos transeúntes convertidos en
rescatistas también salvan a un niño
pequeño
varias regiones de haití han sufrido
importantes daños tras el terremoto de
magnitud 7.2 que azotó el país el sábado
especialmente en las ciudades de lekai y
jamie y
hay muchos heridos casas destruidas y
personas muertes último y en una ciudad
fuera del epicentro el terremoto
interrumpió una eucaristía el sacerdote
y los feligreses subieron los hoteles
también se han visto afectados como este
en la calle cuyo techo se derrumbó sobre
los huéspedes causando numerosas muertes
los hospitales están colapsados por la
cantidad de heridos en este centro
médico de jeremy las víctimas están
siendo tratadas en el suelo debido a la
falta de camas el primer ministro en
hill declaró el estado de emergencia
durante un mes
el gobierno ha decidido esta mañana a
declarar el estado de emergencia durante
un mes tras esta catástrofe bebé de su
población aún sólida y una vez los
pedimos a la población que sea solidaria
evitemos el pánico ante este terremoto
navy de titanic fast
haití todavía está recuperándose del
devastador terremoto de 2010 que mató a
más de 200.000 personas
y que causó grandes daños a las
infraestructuras y a la economía del
país